en su árbol, porque todos estamos conectados,
y 75 millones pueden parecer mucho,
pero en pocos años, es muy probable
que tengamos un árbol genealógico
con todos, o casi todas, las 7 mil millones de personas en la Tierra.
Pero ¿realmente importa?
¿Cuál es la importancia?
Yo creo que es importante,
y les voy a dar 5 razones muy rápidamente.
En primer lugar, tiene valor científico.
Esta es una historia sin precedentes de la raza humana,
y nos está dando datos valiosos
acerca de cómo se heredan las enfermedades,
cómo la gente emigra
y hay un equipo de científicos del MIT ahora
estudiando el árbol genealógico mundial.
Número dos, le da vida a la historia.
Me enteré de que estoy conectado a Albert Einstein,
así que se lo dije a mi hijo de 7 años de edad,
y él estaba totalmente cautivado.
Ahora Albert Einstein no es un hombre blanco muerto
con el pelo raro.
Es el tío Albert. (Risas)
Y mi hijo quería saber,
"¿Qué ha dicho? ¿Qué es E = MC²?"
Además, no todo son buenas noticias.
Me encontré con un enlace a Jeffrey Dahmer, el asesino en serie,
pero he de decir que viene del lado de mi esposa.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Así que quiero que esto quede claro. Lo siento, cariño.
Número tres, la interconexión.
Todos venimos de un mismo ancestro,
y uno no tiene que creer en la versión literal de la Biblia,
pero los científicos hablan del Y cromosomal de Adán
y la Eva mitocondrial,
y estos fueron hace unos 100 000 a 300 000 años.
Todos tenemos un poco de su ADN en nosotros.
Ellos son nuestra tatara-tatara- tatara-tatara-tatara-tatara
—seguir que por cerca de 7000 veces—
abuelos,
y lo que significa, literalmente, es que todos somos
primos biológicos también,
y las estimaciones varían, pero probablemente
el primo más lejano que tienen en la Tierra
se trata de un primo 50°
Ahora, no es sólo que compartimos ancestros, descendientes.
Si tienen niños, y ellos tienen hijos,
miren cómo rápidamente los descendientes se acumulan.
Así que en 10, 12 generaciones,
Uds. van a tener miles de descendientes,
y millones de descendientes.
Número cuatro, un mundo más amable.
Ahora, sé que hay disputas familiares.
Tengo 3 hijos, así que veo cómo se pelean.
Pero creo que también qe hay un sesgo humano
a tratar a su familia un poco mejor que a los extranjeros.
Creo que este árbol va a ser una mala noticia para los fanáticos,
porque van a tener que darse cuenta
de que son primos de miles de personas
en cualquier grupo étnico con el que
tengan problemas,
y creo que uno mira hacia atrás en la historia,
y un montón de las terribles cosas que nos hemos hecho el uno al otro
se debe a que un grupo cree que otro grupo es sub-humano,
y uno no puede hacer eso ya más.
No somos solo una parte de la misma especie,
somos parte de la misma familia.
Compartimos el 99,9 % de nuestro ADN.
Ahora la final es la número cinco,
un efecto democratizador.
Para algunos la genealogía tiene una cepa elitista,
como dice la gente, "Oh, yo soy descendiente
de María, reina de Escocia
y tú no, así que no puedes ingresar a mi club social".
Pero eso va a ser realmente difícil de hacer ahora,
porque todo el mundo está relacionado.
Yo soy descendiente de María reina de Escocia,
por matrimonio, pero aún así.
Así que es realmente un momento fascinante
en la historia de la familia,
porque está cambiando tan rápido.
Hay matrimonios gay y donantes de semen
y hay matrimonios mixtos en una escala sin precedentes,
y esto pone a algunos de mis primos más conservadores
un poco nerviosos,
pero realmente creo que es una buena cosa.
Creo que cuanto más inclusiva es la idea de familia,
mejor,
porque entonces uno tiene más cuidadores potenciales,
y como la prima octava mi dos veces tía lejana
Hillary Clinton dice
—(risas)—
se necesita un pueblo.
Así que tengo todos estos cientos y miles,
millones de nuevos primos.
Pensé, ¿qué puedo hacer con esta información?
Y fue entonces cuando me decidí,
¿por qué no hacer una fiesta?
Así que eso es l o que estoy haciendo.
Y están todos invitados.
El año que viene, el próximo verano,
Seré el anfitrión de lo que espero sea
la reunión de la familia más grande y mejor de la historia.
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Los quiero allí.
Los quiero allí.
Será en el New York Hall of Science,
que es una gran sede,
pero también es el sitio de la antigua Feria Mundial,
que es, creo, muy apropiado,
porque veo esto como una reunión familiar
se reúne una feria mundial.
Habrá exposiciones y comida y música.
Paul McCartney está a 11 pasos de distancia,
así que espero que él traiga su guitarra.
Él no ha respondido todavía, pero cruzo los dedos.
Y no va a ser un día de discursos,
de primos fascinantes.
Es temprano, pero estoy listo,
tengo algunos alineados.
Cass Sunstein, mi primo que es quizás
el jurista más brillante, hablará.
Fue miembro de la administración Obama.
Y en el otro lado del espectro político,
George H.W. Bush, el número 41, el padre,
que ha aceptado participar,
y Nick Kroll, el cómico,
y el Dr. Oz, y muchos más por venir.
Y, por supuesto, los más importantes que son Uds.
Los quiero allá,
y los invito a ir a GlobalFamilyReunion.org
y averiguar cómo están en el árbol de familia,
debido a que estos son temas importantes, familia y tribu,
y no sé todas las respuestas,
pero tengo un montón de parientes inteligentes,
incluidos Uds.,
así que juntos, creo que podemos averiguarlo.
Solo juntos podemos resolver estos grandes problemas.
Así que de primo a primo,
les doy las gracias. No puedo esperar a verte.
Adiós.
(Aplausos)